given Pixar's uneven output when it
comes to sequels and the fact that Toy
Story 3 very much felt like a definitive
wrap-up for the series can a fourth one
be anything other than a waste in
something that undermines what came
before yes it Canada Toy Story 4 I have
had some let's go with unoptimized
feelings about this project you liked
this you spend money on this you want to
spend more money on this how about this
one yeah but you know what and I've said
this in the past but it's been a while
since I've been able to properly put it
into practice I can't remember the last
time I got to but that's it with this
and that is the fact that despite my
very frequently being very skeptical
about a lot of movies that come out I
love being wrong about that and I was
wrong I honestly thought that there was
no way given the way that Toy Story 3
ended and I don't even like Toy Story 3
nearly as much as almost everyone else I
know it's a good movie don't get me
wrong but it's a strong ending and where
do you go from there
I thought there was nowhere for it to go
I thought that there was nothing that
this film could do or offer that
wouldn't just inherently undermine what
came before or make it seem you know
cheap and it doesn't do that this
thing's got a number of things going for
it the first is is that it in no way
tries to replicate
the field the climax or even like the
emotional tones of the third one which
is good and then in addition to that the
whole thing just feels you know what it
is
it doesn't even feel like a cash-grab
follow-up it feels like a coda it feels
like a Daniel MA
it feels like the the come down from the
climate so if we're looking at all four
films you've got your first film that
sets everything up and establishes the
relationships you've got your second
film that escalates and definitely
definitely in terms of the emotional and
it points you toward where things are
going to go and then the third is your
climax both in terms of the emotion and
also like in the lives of these
characters this feels like the most
harrowing thing that they're gonna be
put through and normally in a trilogy
that's where you stop but there's
something to be said for being able to
have a come down from that climax to
have something that just feels like oh
okay
but also is still serving up like a
working story but doesn't feel the need
to reach for what the third one reach
it's just like it's all okay and here
here we go take a breath and it's really
good for that I think part of what was
smart about it is there's the much
bigger emphasis on humor in this I would
say it's the funniest one since the
second it might even be the funniest one
of the series there's a lot of emphasis
on the humor and under other
circumstances I might think they're
doing that because they don't have a
story to actually tell but they do have
a story and but it makes sense for the
way that this wraps things up to have it
feel lighter especially given how heavy
the third one was this is the palate
cleanser this is what leaves you with a
more oh okay then and I'm gone I have to
start getting into spoilers pretty quick
I mean I'll just say it looks great it's
very funny the characters both old and
new
good and well use new characters tend to
get more of a focus than old ones
primary characters are woody bo-peep
who's returning we didn't see her in the
third one but she's been in the series
before and the new character for key are
the major features we also have
additional new characters who are
memorable like Duke kaboom
voiced by Keanu Reeves who's wonderful
and ducky and bunny voiced by IKEA
Michael key and Jordan Peele who are
wonderful and we get to know a little
bit more about Bonnie's family which is
great a lot of the older toys that
aren't woody are kind of sideline buzz
gets a little bit to do Jessie gets a
little bit to do there's a couple of
moments for a characters like Trixie and
dolly but by and large they're just kind
of there but it's okay because this is
very much actually ultimately this is
Woody's story more than anyone else
specifically and it it's it's a good one
it's it's I'm I'm really surprised how
much I like this I like it more than
third one and yet I like while I do
think the third one is overrated in some
circles third one's still very good
movie I like this better and in order to
explain why I gotta start getting into
spoilers so I'm gonna now start to dip
into that so the there's a lot going on
here that makes this feel justified
because things are a big part of what I
was afraid of going to this movie was
okay well we're just gonna go through
the same cycle we went through with Andy
but now it's Bonnie but it is a very
different thing that is going on here
especially in terms of woody what you
realize fairly early on into the movie
and and gets explored as a theme as it
continues is that you realize and this
didn't occur to me before and I'm pretty
sure it didn't occur to woody until now
until the city his situation changed but
a big part of his undying devotion to
Andy and him always pushing everybody we
need to be here for Andy a big part of
what gave him the drive to do that
was the fact that he was the favorite he
was Andy's favorite toy he's not
Bonnie's favorite toy sorry Bonnie
doesn't love him it doesn't play with
him but he's not the favorite and he
knows that and he's finding himself with
a little less purpose than he had before
not no purpose he's not listless but the
passion for what he does
can't be at the same level because the
appreciation of who of what he is isn't
as high with Bonnie as it was with Andy
and that's not portrayed as a fault of
Bonnie that's just the nature of this it
can't always be the same the second time
around and you can take that into any
number of extrapolations for any number
of different kinds of relationships
whether it be romantic relationships
familial relationships you know it's not
you can't get what you had before with
someone new it's gonna be its own thing
and that may include being slightly less
fulfilling and that's where beau comes
in now Bo Peep voiced by any potts who I
like anyway so that's nice she did like
they do a great setup with her first of
all explaining why she wasn't in the
third film in the opening segment that
works very well but also creates a great
through line and wonderful payoff for
the end because here's your big big big
spoilers is your last warning would he
leaves the toys and goes to be with Bo
and Bo's a lost toy she doesn't belong
to anybody
and woody chooses that because he's
reached a point and a circumstance where
being there for Bonnie isn't meaningless
but he's never gonna be appreciated for
doing that the way he was being there
for Andi and maybe it's time for him to
do something for himself instead of just
for his kid and maybe that's maybe he's
earned that maybe he needs that and
that's the decision he ultimately makes
and it feels
right and it feels earned and it feels
like a nice additional conclusion cuz as
much as the third film was the end of
Andy's story it was the end of the story
of these toys as Andy's toys this feels
like the conclusion of Woody's story
specifically and that feels like a good
note to go out on and I would be very
surprised if they announced a toy store
or five actually partly because I know
that the opening weekend was not bad but
kind of soft by Disney Pixar standards
so I'd be surprised if we've got a fifth
one but I also like I mean granted I
already thought there was nowhere to go
after the third one but like they
managed to pull rabbit out of a hat and
give us this but I'd like I would be
very skeptical if they wanted to try and
roll the dice on that a second time
especially like it would either have to
be a movie without woody period or
they'd have to come up with something
very contrived reason to bring him back
with the rest of the group which would
feel like it's undoing this and this is
just nice and sweet and forkie is his
very much
my daughter loved for he she thought he
was hilarious now porky does if you are
a nitpicker for logistics for key raises
a lot of questions about how any of this
works and the film itself kind of hangs
a lampshade on that because it has like
little snippets during the like the
first half of the credits before it just
becomes you know the scroll of names
they have little bits and one of them
being 4q basically saying flat out I
don't know how any of this works and I
feel like that's the that's the
filmmakers acknowledging like please
don't think too much about this just
roll with us on this so I know there are
like the big weird unifying theories of
Pixar movies where somehow they're all
taking place in the same universe oh boo
is in Bonnie's kindergarten class so you
know there's your connection for this
but you know
the rules are weird anyone who wants to
try and figure that out I guess I'm not
gonna tell people not to cuz I guess
people have fun doing that kind of
theorist stuff but like there's no
secret code here just just roll with it
I also like that this film ultimately
doesn't have a villain which is another
thing that makes it feel like a nice
calm coda to the overall series because
obviously the first time we had Sid
which was you know the kid who didn't
take proper care of his toys sort of
broke the toy owner relationship then we
had the prospector who just didn't have
an appreciation for what it meant to be
loved by a child because he never had
one and then the third film we have
Lotso who did know the level of a child
but then got burned when that was taken
away from him and that twisted him and
it's nice that we kind of gets that we
get Gaby here and she's set up very much
like she's gonna be the villain but
she's not not really she's a little
naive she's a little self-centered but
she's not evil and what she wants is
incredibly relatable especially for the
other toys which is why would he gives
her his voice box and I did kind of like
that initially she doesn't get what she
wants because of that because you don't
just get you don't get one thing and
suddenly everything the world works
that's not life there's no magic pill to
suddenly make everything okay but they
were still able to give her a nice
satisfying and for her part in the story
and also part of what made her seem like
a villain is they really lead into how
I'm settling ventriloquist dummies were
they've got her as they've got them as
her henchman so yeah that leaned into
that pretty nicely um I also like I do
want to sing about Bonnie as well it's
funny thinking back on it like it
occurred to me how little we actually
know Andy despite
like that he was in three films because
by and large we only really get to know
Andy through Woody's love of him we
don't actually see Andy himself all that
much spend all that much time with just
getting to know him as a character
Bonnie we get quite a bit of time with
and which is nice especially given like
as I said I'd be surprised if there's a
fifth one so it's it feels nice that in
this just you know this and her
introduction of the cream you still feel
like we really get to know her and they
kept her very well like head being the
the father of a young daughter I can
recognize a lot of what they managed to
capture like yep yep oh yeah yeah yeah
so I was kind of doing that in my head
for so much of Bonnie's stuff so that
was really cool and she was really sweet
it's just it's just a nice movie and
especially given how add I think I even
used the word already harrowing the
third film was especially towards the
end of it it's it felt good to just come
in and have a nice movie this is just
nice and sweet and endearing and I think
I kind of love it
Toy Story 4 completely caught me off
guard by being excellent not just good
like excellent huh it's genuinely nice
to be wrong sometimes Toy Story 4 have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it a whole bunch of stuff to do
because there's buttons and links and
all that stuff for you to go on and poke
and prod and push buttons but I'm also
not gonna make you do it I appreciate it
absolutely the patreon especially but at
the end of the day folks you know what
you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]